gilles verdez parce qu'il gagne le
scénario il faut se trouve quelqu'un
pour le calmer je pense que je peux être
son grand frère malgré son âge je crois
je viens pour m'amuser moi bordel je
serais pour m'amuser moi quand je la
préfère longtemps sous la peau perd du
temps où nous virer matthieu delormeau
[Rires]
voilà il faut pas être là en même temps
les gars donc lorsque m'a tuer la juge
il n'est pas là lorsque j'étais là match
c'est pareil ça va tout résoudre
moi personnellement non je crois je
préparais si mokhtar a perdu je vais
forcément perdre mukhtar en fait chaud
avec toi donc si tu perds joue perso tu
gagnes tu gagnes grand plaisir agathe
quel parfum